the glass armonica really had this
effect on people who heard it I mean
they were saying it was the most
beautiful sound they'd ever heard and
there were a lot of beautiful sounds in
the 18th century but you know there was
something different in the sound of the
harmonica I wanted to give people that
come to Williamsburg and experience that
they wouldn't get anywhere else I'm
Chris funk I'm a musician in a band
called The Decemberists and I'm on a
journey looking for the most surprising
and extraordinary people in music my
next stop takes me to Williamsburg
Virginia there I will meet one of the
last true masters of an enchanting
instrument forgotten by time
[Music]
I've traveled to Virginia and step back
into history to meet a musician who is
perfected a rather unusual medium glass
my name is Dean Shah stack here in
Williamsburg Virginia where I live and I
play the glass armonica but I also play
a number of other glass instruments too
like this crystal Bosch a Dean has spent
years mastering the skills necessary to
play this family of glass instruments
all of which originated with the glass
armonica an instrument with a very
unexpected Creator
[Music]
the glass harmonica was invented by
Benjamin Franklin in 1761 he had seen
somebody play on the wine glasses and a
concert and he got the idea that you
could actually use glass in an entirely
different way you could actually make
them rotate with a flywheel you're
working with your foot and with wet
fingers you can play it very much like a
keyboard
[Music]
obviously you don't tune this instrument
no that's the one nice thing everybody
has to tune to me first thing I need to
do is get your hands really clean and
that takes a high calcium content the
water which they happen to have here at
this theater so I've got these jugs but
I literally actually bring the water
from the theater back to my house to
have the same water to play with all the
time the skin absorbs moisture and so
you really want your hands to start
wrinkling up a little bit to the
condition of the skin on your fingers is
really what produces the sounds and
those mesmerizing sounds produced by
skin on glass are not limited to the
glass armonica or the crystal Bechet the
technique has led to some truly bizarre
instruments
[Applause]
[Music]
I've heard the argument made that you
know we've gone as far as we can with
acoustic instruments if you think about
glass music as a still unexplored
musical frontier it's pretty exciting to
think what instruments we could try and
glass you know but we don't know until
we do we make these instruments where
they're gonna be like I think we should
know about the glass harmonica because
it's truly the first American instrument
you know aside from the Native American
instruments already here I absolutely
had to teach myself how to play my only
sources were reading what Franklin wrote
in these other guys back in the time it
is new every day every time I still
don't play the harmonica it is a fresh
experience and a challenge each time
you
[Music]